استشهد 15 شخصا واصيب العشرات جراء قصف
اسرائيلي استهدف ديوان عائله حمدان في احد
احياء خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه وتؤوي
المنطقه التي تعرضت منازلها لدمار كبير
نازحين من شمال قطاع
غزه
والله قاعدين في الهلال احنا
نازحين سمعنا صوت الصاروخ تقول هز خن يونس
هز اجينا نجري طبعا احنا هنا نا حي الامل
جيران واللي هنا نازحين من
براجع لقينا اشلاء في الشارع مقطعين هنا
وهنا اشلاء وهنا ايد وهنا رجل زي ما انت
شايف كله قاعد بلملم في
الاشياء حسبي الله ونعم الو
باار يا عم مش عند الارض يا عم مش مشكله خ
راعين
الحمال يا خال هي
[تصفيق]
كي
واح خلص
طعنا هذا دوان لدار حمدان كان ستقبل
نازحين من شمال من عند جباليه اجوا
النازحين استقبلنا بكل حب وا احترام زي ما
انتم شايفين طائرات الاحتلال قصفت المكان
على النازحين اللي فيه كان في تقريبا فوق
فوق 30 نفر مش مش ندور عليهم مش ملاق اطلع
انتم شايفين المكان وت عارفين ودوان دارم
مجزره صارم اني مجزره بحق
عائلتنا تعال هنا يا ابو اللحم تعال هنا
تعال اطلع
فوق